jeopardy began to air alex trebek's
final episodes last night
alex filmed these final episodes just 10
days before he passed away
he had just been in the hospital for
surgery to treat his pancreatic cancer
producers were ready to cancel the shoot
completely but alex insisted that he
would be there
yeah executive producer mike richards
told entertainment weekly as i mentioned
he'd been out with the surgery and i
wasn't sure he'd be back to take those
days
so for the few of us that knew what
exactly was going on there was a
heightened sense in the room
on that first episode trebek walked out
and you'll see it when it airs
he gives us amazing speech about the
holidays and coming together
and being strong and taking care of each
other and we didn't know he was going to
do that he just walked out and did it
you'll see in the episode we all started
to clap and there's points in jeopardy
where you clap
there's points in jeopardies where you
don't that's not a normal spot you can
see your back kind of look over at
us as he was crossing to reveal the
categories what are you guys clapping
about
so ken jennings who will serve as the
first guest host next week
was on good morning america today but
first here's that moment on jeopardy
last night
and now here is
thank you johnny hello ladies and
gentlemen you'll recall that about a
month ago i asked all of you to take a
moment to give
thanks for all of the blessings that you
enjoy in your lives
now today a different kind of message
this is the season
of giving i know you want to be generous
with your family your friends your loved
ones
but today i'd like you to go one step
further i'd like you to open up your
hands
and open up your heart to those who are
still suffering
because of covet 19 people who are
suffering
through no fault of their own we're
trying to build a gentler kinder society
and if we all pitch in
just a little bit we're going to get
there okay teal david and braden
good luck here we go into the jeopardy
round i spoke to him on the phone
actually the weekend he passed and he
was
he was frail but he was still very much
alex and i remember him
just being very confident in me to be a
guest host if he ever needed that you
know we were we were hoping we'd have
him with us for longer
but i remember i was reminded of the
thing he always emphasized about the
show which was
he's not the star of the show you know
the host is not the star of jeopardy he
always made it about the players and
about the competition
it's just hard to imagine that in the tv
landscape today
a star of his size saying hey the game
is not about you but that was great
advice
yeah so there was uh people that are
watching can hear what we just played
roz and keisha and i just couldn't hear
what was played but yeah i mean pretty
amazing alex as well
it reminds me a little bit of uh with
chadwick boseman the
messages that we heard him text people
or what he told people in his final
months that
you wonder in this circumstance too did
alex trebek you know have a sense that
his
you know these were his final days or
his his times limited raws do you think
yeah i think he did because i know that
um
when mike was doing interviews he had
said that
he talked to alex the week before and
what they just said which is that you
know he was excited because he was in
the hospital
and that day he managed to keep down
jell-o you know and
when you've dealt with anything like
this where somebody is sick you know
when they're when they're happy and
getting down jello
is that is the milestone of the day you
know that they don't have long
and yeah when they wanted to cancel the
whole thing and alex said don't cancel
it i will be there
and he was and we can't say it enough of
just how much of an incredible person
and just how
committed to the fans and this show and
i don't think it had anything to do with
his own legacy
he just wanted to work on the thing that
he loved until the day he couldn't
anymore and he did
yeah oh my goodness yeah i feel like for
people who are
sick and who are going through things
like this um
they want to have some sense of normalcy
they don't want to
be just in the hospital or just be sick
as much as they can be if they have a
little bit of strength or a little bit
of spark or energy
they want to jump on it they want to you
know take that momentum and it really
just shows
yeah his passion for what he does and
i'm just so grateful that we got that
i'm grateful that we got that energy out
of him the last bit that we got and
um it just it's so meaningful so this is
really this is great
yeah sanders says alex is a class act
100 percent rest in peace
agent says a true canadian legend rest
in peace
hector says alex trebek is iconic and
made jeopardy what it is today
yeah it's going to be interesting like
i'm surprised that ken jennings is doing
uh interviews already he his main
purpose was promoting another game show
called the chase i believe
but obviously he was talking about
jeopardy as well it seems a little bit
in poor taste to be
talking about how he's going to be a
guest host when alex trebek's final
episodes are airing
so it'll be next week that we see ken
jennings a host yeah
it's going to be interesting to see how
that goes
yeah i don't know i think that it would
have been insensitive had he been
talking about how he's going to guest
host after alex dies
but i i know that it feels like alex is
still with us
because of the messages just so much new
there's so much
new emotion you know from alex and
nobody knew
i didn't know that that was going to be
on last night he was going to say that
so yes it does feel insensitive but you
know but alex
is alex is gone and um and that's i
think
part of the reason why it does feel
crass to hear kenz jennings talk about
you know how he's going to take over
yeah it's been two months since he
passed so